Democrats decide it's very important to
attack a federal judge candidate on her
religion Hillary Clinton decides that
it's very important to attack Bernie
Sanders and Donald Trump decides it's
very important to attack the Republican
Party everything's messed up I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show so
you made it finally we're all the way to
a Friday and we have the mailbag coming
up a little bit later in the show so if
you're gonna subscribe now is the time
to do it so you can be part of today's
mailbag where we will indeed be taking
live questions but before we get to all
of the various topics of the day and
myriad they are first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at bowl
and branch so as I've said a thousand
times on the show I'm really bad at
sleep sleep is not my forte but I used
to be much worse at sleep thanks to
Bolin Branch I sleep a lot better at
night and that's because they make the
best sheets on the market they're so
good that when I buy new sheets for my
kids the only sheets that I will buy our
bolin branch eat says how good these
sheets are these sheets are used by 3x
presidents and bill clinton's lovers if
he's one of them and bolin bran sheets
are that they breathe they're
comfortable you don't know that you're
sleeping on a bad sheet until you
actually sleep on a good sheet it
actually sort of spoils you once you
sleep on a good sheet you never want to
go back to sleeping on the plastic tarps
they give you at the car wash ever again
instead you're gonna want to go over to
bowl and branch and get their sheets
right now each of their sheets is
crafted from 100% organic cotton and not
only feel incredible they look great and
they are half the price of a typical
sheet of this quality that you would get
at some retail store half the price for
twice the quality you will love the
sheets try them out for 30 nights and
see for yourself if you're not impressed
you can return them for a full refund I
have yet to personally identify anybody
who's actually done that because the
sheets are just that comfortable go to
bull and branch come today it's bol el
and branch calm today you will get $50
off your first set of sheets plus free
shipping when you use the promo code
betting it's $50 off your first set of
sheets Plus free shipping when you use
promo code Ben 50 bucks off plus the
free shipping and again if you don't
like them you try them for 30 nights you
don't like them feel free to send them
back and they will refund them to you
SPO Bo LL and branch calm promo code Ben
use that promo code Ben 50 bucks off
plus it lets them know that we sent you
the most comfortable sheets on the
market okay so there is a lot to talk
about with
to President Trump and his move to the
left on deferred action for childhood
arrivals basically saying that he now
wants the DREAM Act the same DREAM Act
that he ripped you Bush up-and-down for
will also talk about Trump going
Democrat on the debt ceiling what that
means why that's important a lot of
people today sort of brushing off the
debt ceiling discussion well we always
raise the debt ceiling what's the big
deal
well raising the debt ceiling you should
at least get one of two things if you're
the governing party you should at least
get one of two things out of the debt
ceiling one some sort of systemic change
to spending that would actually make
sure that you're not taking out as much
debt in the future right get some
spending cuts in exchange for increasing
the debt ceiling or extending the debt
ceiling or to you blow off the debt
ceiling entirely for like another 18
months you don't have to do this for
every three months from now until the
end of time so the Democrats can hold up
the debt ceiling so that they can spend
more money all right you wanna get one
of those two things from got neither of
those two things it's a bad deal and it
also puts a lot of pressure on
Republicans because he also pushed
forward a continuing resolution a budget
resolution that only goes through
December so now Republicans are
basically stacked up by December they
now have to pass reckon so if they want
to do Obamacare repeal they have to do
it like basically in the next three
weeks if they want to do tax reform they
have to do it before December and they
have to do it with that deadline looming
in December because remember right now
Republicans only have 52 votes in the
Senate that means that if they want to
pass anything with 51 votes through
reconciliation then they need
reconciliation rules require any bill
you pass has to be revenue neutral well
how do you gauge whether a bill is
revenue neutral the way that you gauge
whether a bill is revenue neutral is
based on the baseline budget it's based
on the budget so that means that they
have to have a budget in place so that
means Democrats can hold up anything in
December by saying we're not going to
pass any sort of budget we're going to
set off on the sidelines and not pass
any part of your new budget and
therefore you can't even get a
reconciliation ruling on some of these
tax reform bills that the Senate wants
to take up it's really a problem
basically Trump gave them a lot of
leverage come December we'll talk about
all that but first I want to get to an
issue that has been very under covered
right now what we're watching in the
United States and it's very disturbing
is a loss of religion across the board
in the United States there's a poll that
came out this week about evangelical
Christians showing that a huge number of
evangelical Christians we're now
uncertain on basic protocol principles
basic doctrinal principles like is
promiscuity bad I mean these things are
pretty clear in the back
you may not actually fulfill the mandate
right you mates in we all sin we get
that but there are certain things that
in Christian doctrine are pretty pretty
well clear and doesn't again doesn't
mean you uphold them personally or that
you don't sin but there are certain
things that are that are pretty clear in
Christian doctrine evangelical
Christians those numbers are sliding
among evangelical Christians among
people who actually believe in the
doctrine there's a poll out this week
showing that we've never reached an
all-time high in the United States of
people who describe themselves as
non-believers people who feel that they
are not religious and this is something
that's cheered and pushed by the secular
left and it's not just cheered and
pushed by the secular left there's an
all-out assault that's happening from
the Democratic left on people of
religious faith because the idea on a
lot of the left is that religion leads
to these hard and fast rules and these
hard and fast rules are bad rules right
their ancients and they're bad and
they're bigoted in there they're
backwards if we just got rid of all of
those rules then life would be so much
better I just gotta get rid of religion
force people to bring their religion up
to snuff make that if they're gonna
believe in religion make let them be
spiritual not religious right they can
believe in some higher power sure as
long as it doesn't actually impact what
they do in the here and now and we're
gonna browbeat anyone who actually
believes this stuff if you actually
believe religious principle if you
actually believe religious doctrine
we're gonna beat you up for it so the
best case in point that I've seen in
recent history is is what happened in
the Senate Judiciary Committee this
would be now a couple of days ago so
there is a judge who is whose name is
Amy Barrett she's actually a professor
at Notre Dame law and she's being
appointed to the appeals court the
Seventh Circuit Court of Appeals or
she's being considered for that and
Dianne Feinstein the senator from
California decided to go after her why
because this law professor is a Catholic
and she wrote a piece years ago in which
she suggested that if you're a Catholic
and you have to sit in on a death
penalty case then you should probably
excuse yourself you should recuse
yourself because as a religious person
you have a duty not to actually vote in
favor of the death penalty so the best
thing you can do is recuse yourself now
no there's a difference between recusing
yourself and voting against the death
penalty in a particular case recusing
yourself means you don't get a vote
that's the purpose of a recusal
but the way that Dianne Feinstein the
Democrats play this was while she's
saying that your religion should infuse
your
she's saying your religion should impact
your rulings that if your ruling is is
going to go against what you believe
religiously that she's saying that your
religion should take precedence that's
not what she's saying at all that's not
what she's saying at all but Feinstein
basically goes after and she says listen
if you're a religious Catholic you
shouldn't be on the court you shouldn't
have a place in public life
here's Dianne Feinstein from California
when you read your speeches the
conclusion one draws is that the dogma
lives loudly within you and that's of
concern when you come to big issues that
large numbers of people have fought for
for years in this country
okay so what what they're really
questioning her about is this 1998 paper
that she wrote as a law student along
with John Garvey HughesNet president of
the Catholic University of America that
is according to the Atlantic in the
paper the two authors explore whether a
Catholic judge should recuse herself
from death penalty cases if she would be
unable to impartial II uphold the law
because of her religious convictions the
Pope and the American bishops have
recently offered clear and forceful
denunciations of the punishment they
said and many Catholics feel morally
obligated to uphold the teachings of the
church in certain limited circumstances
they argue federal judges should step
back from involvement in cases that
might raise conflicts of interest they
didn't argue the judge should step back
from morally complicated cases all or
even most of the time according to
Garvey he said it turns out the number
of cases in which we thought and
adherence to your moral principles would
prevent you from deciding a case
according to the law was much smaller
than we imagined but again notice
basically Feinstein is saying you
shouldn't be a judge because if you're a
judge then that means that you're going
to use your religious doctrine in order
to target people but that's exactly what
the paper is not saying the paper is
saying precisely the reverse the paper
is saying if I have to rule along side
my religious doctrine and it would
impact how I roll along inside the law
then I'm gonna recuse myself but the
idea here is that if you're Catholic you
can't be trusted
you're one of those shifty Papists one
of those shifty evil Papists and it
wasn't just fine steam ok was also dick
durbin the the senator from Illinois
fellow Chicago I believe is the most
Catholic city in the United States
Durbin is amazing get away with this but
this demonstrates the level of
secularism that is now in
parents in our public discourse here's
Durban going after her on the same
grounds it is relevant in that you have
many times spoken out as a professor and
as a lawyer about the burden and
opportunity presented by your faith this
article of twenty years ago which you
wrote with John Garvey as I understand
it you now say you don't agree with is
that correct okay so the idea here is
that she she is she's a bad person she's
Catholic can't be trusted and this is
what the left hard left truly believes
about religion movie into the mainstream
left remember Hillary Clinton said in
the last election cycle that people who
are religious who believe certain things
about same-sex marriage for example they
have to update their religion to take
accounts of the times yeah that is not
her decision to make that is not her
decision to make and yet it's so funny
because the left will then use religion
as a club when they feel that it's
convenient right so james Clyburn who is
a a representative he came out and he
said that anybody who is Christian or
Jewish should obviously be in favor of
the dreamers because otherwise they'd be
violating their their own religious
precepts this representative Clyburn
Democrat of South Carolina they love
this country and many of them this is
the only country they have ever known
and for us to hold the children
responsible for the sins of their
parents defies who and what we are as a
nation and those people who belittle
mentalism christianity and judaism ought
to practice what we say we we preach
okay so the idea is that religion is bad
unless i wish to invoke it in which case
religion becomes good or there's no
actual concerted principle here there's
no actual line of demarcation the boston
globe around a long piece this week
talking specifically about elizabeth
warren's faith okay Elizabeth Warren is
the most pro-abortion member of the US
Senate but she's a deep believer you
know she's a deep believer basically
religion is something that Democrats can
say they actually like when it's
convenient but the minute that you
actually say my religious values inform
my values generally then all of a sudden
you're a bad person unless of course
you're a leftist then if you're a
leftist then you can get away with it no
problem this is a serious problem for
Democrats and
to explain why in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over the u.s. concealed-carry
Association so it's the middle of the
night and you hear somebody at the door
not somebody knocking at the door
somebody pounding at the door somebody
breaking down the door somebody breaking
through the door you go to you're safe
you get out your gun you load up and
then there's the guy and you shoot him
because he's in your house what the
hell's you doing there okay you think
this is where the story ends you've just
done something good you've protected
yourself and your family in your own
home that's not where the story ends the
cops show up they're gonna ask you a
bunch of questions they may arrest you
because that's just the way the law
works well this is why you need to talk
to my friends over at the u.s. CCA go to
defend my family now calm right now they
have a copy of a free guide that will
uncover the six things you didn't know
what happened when the police arrived
again it's called the six things you
didn't know what happened when the
police arrived because of the fact is
you think the end of the story is the
shooting it isn't there's a lot more and
if you're not careful you could wind up
in jail for something that you shouldn't
wind up in jail for go to defend my
family now calm right now to get your
copy of that free guide again defend my
family now calm also they will will
provide for you insurance that prevents
against loss in these cases meaning that
if you have to hire a lawyer if you have
to have bail right they have services
that provide for all of these things
this will defend my family now calm is
for and right now you get the US CCA's
free guide that will uncover the things
you need to know in case of a shooting
scenario because again you're not gonna
be immediately hailed as a hero you may
in fact be arrested so defend my family
now calm again let's defend my family
now calm for all that information plus
the free guide great people they do
wonderful work okay so here is the
problem
right now we're polarized along so many
lines in the United States we're
polarized along racial lines Barack
Obama spent a lot of time between 2008
and 2016 polarizing us along racial
lines for political gain and I do think
that there is an element in the 2016
election in which President Trump
basically signaled to a lot of people
that there was going to be a new white
identity politics in response to the
Barack Obama minority identity politics
basically Democrats had for years and
years and years there's this growing
majority right there's this new majority
it's not gonna include white people
those horrible white privileged white
supremacist jackasses there though those
people who have taken over the United
States and used it for their own benefit
for the last 200 years they're gonna be
out on their butts and a lot of
people say wait what the heck like we
didn't do any of that sit like what what
now and Trump said to them listen I'm
your guy right I'm the guy who's going
to defend you against the people who say
that you need to not have any power in
the system anymore so a white identity
politics sort of sprung up and you can
see that in the voting statistics the
voting statistics in the 2016 election
cycle I mean if you look at blue collar
white voters they voted overwhelmingly
for president trauma I mean by a huge
number I'm looking at the the numbers
right now and in in these areas White's
without a college degree whites with no
college degree well okay
whites with no college degree with a
shifted from about 25 points more
Republican in 2004 to nearly forty
points more Republican in 2016 that's a
massive shift okay is a huge shift and
basically they voted like a voting bloc
right we're constantly talking about the
Hispanic voting bloc or the black voting
bloc okay they voted like their own
racial voting bloc blue-collar white
voters they voted more Republican than
Hispanics voted Democrat in this last
election cycle which is an amazing
statistic there's a really incredible
statistic hey that's one polarization
then we've been polarized along class
lines this is what Bernie Sanders wants
to do he wants to polarize us along
lines of classing all the poor people
versus the 1% the 1% the evil 1% which
does include people like me but don't
worry I am great right he wants to
polarize us along those lines and that's
why I see Occupy Wall Street and that's
why you see all of these social justice
movements designed to tear down the rich
and then you've got polarizations along
sex lines this is what Hillary Clinton
was trying to do there's a war on women
and that's why I'm not president because
there's a war on women right this is the
routine that you got from the entire
Democratic Party Katy Perry and the like
that there was some sort of glass
ceiling Republicans had set up and we
have to bust through it like a firework
right that's what we have to do that and
and now the Democrats are basically
driving a response on religion this is
gonna be the next battleground Democrats
believe that there's a rising majority
of people who are secular and don't like
religion and those people are gonna form
their new majority and the more
dismissive and derisive they are about
religion the more they will win and
people are going to backlash against
this there's gonna be a strong religious
backlash against this people saying you
leave me the hell alone
and the problem with the backlash is
every backlash has an element that is a
little bit too far so you will see
people saying things like and let's
reinsurance um laws that that are sort
of religious in nature there will be a
few people who say stuff like that
because they're back lashing like I
don't think that'll be the great
majority but you are going to see
religious people start to identify as a
political bloc of their own that's what
you're gonna see none of this is good
right we all used to be people of random
colors and that didn't matter so much I
would say even ten years ago before
Obama's election you look at the polls
we all used to be people in America who
aspired to be rich but we didn't rip
each other down for what we earned right
we all used to be people who are men and
women people who loved each other but we
didn't break each shed each other down
according to which member of the sexual
identity group you were and we all used
to be people who have religion didn't
have religion but that was your personal
decision and that could infuse your life
how you thought how you saw fit small
government allows for all of that small
government means that I'm gonna you I'm
not going to use the government as a
weapon against you and you're not gonna
use the government as weapon against me
but now religious people look at people
like dianne feinstein and they look at
dick Durbin and they look at james
Clyburn
and they look at Elizabeth Warren and
they look at Hillary Clinton and they
say to themselves these people are
coming after me they're coming after my
children they want me to give up on how
I raise my children they want me to give
up my religious values they think they
know better than I do right now that's
why the masterpiece cake shop case that
is going to go to the Supreme Court next
year it's gonna be so crucial in I think
the next step of societal breakdown very
good shot that Justice Anthony Kennedy
rules that you as a religious person
cannot live out your religious faith in
a business setting even if it's your own
business that if I have a business and I
say listen I'm not up for catering your
same-sex and wedding you know you're
fine I'm not up for catering your
same-sex wedding I'm not using the
government's crackdown on you good shot
the Democrats and Anthony Kennedy and
all these people get together and
basically say religious people do not
have the ability to live out their
religious lifestyle you know what that's
gonna do it's gonna mean that religious
people vote 90% for Republicans that's
where this is gonna go Senator Mike Lee
gets this exactly right senator from
Utah he says to Democrats what you're
doing right now is dividing the country
this country is divided enough millions
of Americans filled up Washington DC
and the dominant culture despised them
and how could they're not when they see
their leaders sitting here grilling
patriotic citizens about their faith
like inquisitors how could they not feel
like their values are not welcome in
this chamber within this government
religious freedom is of deep concern to
me as a Mormon my church members of the
Church of Jesus Christ of latter-day
saints have weathered extraordinary
religious persecution and much of it
especially initially was sponsored by
government actors okay and what we is
saying here is exactly right so what are
Democrats replacing religion with the
answer is that our placement with the
religion of their own best example of
this so yesterday Betsy DeVos who is the
Secretary of Education
she rescinded the so-called Dear
Colleague letter the Dear Colleague
letter was a letter from the Obama
administration to college administrators
I believe it's 2013 and it basically
said to them if there is sexual assault
or sexual harassment on your campus then
you are not allowed to simply dump it
off on the police this constitutes a
title mine violation under the Civil
Rights Act and that means that we will
either prosecute your or remove your
funding because this is sexual
discrimination that if somebody is raped
on your campus when you don't do enough
to do enough to stop it then this will
actually creates a an excuse for us to
remove all of the cash from your campus
and so what the colleges do they were
told what to do the Obama administration
told them what you need to do right now
is you need to set up tribunals campus
tribunals these kangaroo courts I guess
Spanish Inquisition no one expects it
but there it is there needs to be a
Spanish Inquisition on campuses anybody
who's accused of sexual harassment or
sexual assault has to be tried by you
but we're not gonna use a beyond a
reasonable doubt standard we're not even
going to use a strong and clear and
convincing evidence standard instead
we're going to use a preponderance of
the evidence standard so Elliot Hamilton
has a very good piece on this over at
daly wire today he talks about this that
the Dear Colleague letter substantially
lowered the burden of proof required for
college administrators to determine
whether an alleged rapist or sexual
assault are committed a heinous act the
preponderance of evidence is the
of proof required for civil offenses to
show that evidence is at least fifty
percent more likely to have shown
responsibility for an act one of the
most fundamental aspects of criminal law
is that prosecutors need to prove beyond
a reasonable doubt that an alleged
criminal both acted in immoral manner
and possess the requisite mental intent
to commit the crime but the Dear
Colleague letter gets rid of that and
these are kangaroo courts abused by
radicals
Tianna low a National Review explained
quote there's another side to the
system's evil one that has been drowned
out by social justice blathering and a
select few girls who cried rape because
the guidelines are vague and
uninstructed in crucial aspects such as
the rights of sexual assault victims and
the accused as well as the standards for
keeping public statistics of conviction
rates schools vary widely in how they
treat these cases ranging from extreme
bias against men accused of sexual
assaults to cruel prejudice against
sexual assault victims every school that
reaches a guilty verdict without so much
as text messages submitted as evidence
there's another willing to exonerate a
wealthy student at any cost
hey this gets rid of the due rights for
the accused it gets rid of the the I
guess it was a 2011 letter it gets rid
of the due rights the due process rights
of the accused and this is obviously
it's obviously anti-american it's
obviously a serious problem but what the
Democrats do what people are left is
they say if you want any sort of legal
standard actually upheld here for people
accused of sexual assault then that
means that you must side with the
rapists you must side with the right
it's sort of a New Salem witch trial
right your witch if you float right if
you decide that you don't like these
standards then that must mean that you
are a witch right obviously you're pro
rape if you want people convicted of
rape to actually have to have evidence
proved against them hey this is a
religious standard and that's because
the left has a religious belief that
anybody who claims victimhood must be
considered a victim I must of course you
are a straight white male if you're a
straight white male and you claim
victimhood that's because you're a
whiner but if you're not a straight
white male and you claim that you've
been victimized in any sort of scenario
then that means we have to believe you
without evidence now you may have been a
victim okay I'm not making light of
people who are actual sexual assault
victims people who sexually assault as
I've said a thousand times should be put
in jail for life castrated or killed or
all three okay all of these are
acceptable to me but the idea that that
you're going to set up your own sort of
religious tribunal that secularism
doesn't
come with radicalism the secularism
doesn't come with this sort of
inquisitorial mindset of his own it's
just not true now in a minute I want to
talk about what President Trump is doing
to work with Democrats and what impact
this is gonna have on Republicans going
forward but first I want to say thank
you to Dollar Shave Club so Dollar Shave
Club is the smarter choice he has an
Orthodox Jew I don't shave above my
jawline with eight with a straightedge
but I do shave below my jawline with a
straightedge according to Maimonides
that is perfectly okay and I can tell
you the Dollar Shave Club makes the best
razors they make the best shave butter
when I use my DSC executive razor with
their dr. Carver shea butter the blade
gently glides giving a really smooth
shave okay it helps prevent ingrown
hairs and fights razor bumps it's
transparent for a more precise shave you
don't have all of the of the white gunk
on yourself so you don't have to worry
about not being able to see the hair
right you're sort of randomly poking
around with with a razor trying to get
the hair that's underneath you don't
have to do that with dr. Carver's shea
butter it is awesome and right now for a
limited time new members get their first
month of the executive razor with a tube
of dr. Carver's shaved butter for only
five bucks with Free Shipping and after
that they send you razors right for just
a few bucks a month you subscribe and
they send you razors every month that
means they're never gonna be stuck with
the dull blade which is the worst try
shave them with it all blade it is
garbage hey that's a $15 value for only
five dollars and in your first month box
you get an awesome weighty handle it
handles really nice a full cassette of
four cartridges and a tube of their
shave butter and then after the first
month replacement car precision ship
automatically at their regular price no
hidden fees no commitments you can
cancel anytime you like join the club
today at dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben
again when you use that slash Ben and
get your first month of the executive
razor with a tube of their dr. Carver's
shave butter for just five bucks plus
free shipping instead of $15 you get it
for five bucks try it out you're never
going to want to go back to the grocery
store and pick up the the razors again
it's it's too expensive it's overpriced
that's why Dollar Shave Club exists
go check them out right now
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben that also
lets them know that we sent you okay so
in in other POW in other political
matters
president Trump has gone full Democrat
on daca on the on the executive amnesty
he's also going full Democrat
the debt-ceiling okay and this is a
serious problem okay I'll let on the
debt ceiling well let mark Meadows who's
one of the heads of the freedom caucus
explain why this is a serious problem
with the debt ceiling because it is a
serious problem with the debt ceiling I
think the the cliff that it sets up in
December right before Christmas is is
certainly not good but it does show and
you you always look for a silver lining
and that's one of the things that I'm
looking for is in this particular thing
it shows that the president is
myopically focused on tax reform I think
what we we have is is certainly word of
people blindsided yes was I surprised
without a doubt and I think for for many
of us there was not a conservative
solution out there you know and so so
people want to criticize the the Trump
administration for making this call we
were talking about a clean debt ceiling
you know months ago you and I talked it
out that months ago and so as we look at
this if there's not a conservative
alternative why should you get surprised
alternative Meadows could have provided
it and Trump could have gone along with
it but Trump didn't do any of those
things the idea there was nothing on the
table that was better than what Trump
did here is just not true what he's
saying here about this this cliff this
fiscal cliff you remember we've done
this a few times before
basically in December we're going to hit
the end of the budget and Republicans
are gonna have to pass a new continuing
resolution if on the budget
plus we're going to hit the debt ceiling
again and that means Republicans are
gonna have to push off the debt ceiling
Democrats are going to try to extract
some sort of concessions in return for
the budget and the debt ceiling now
meadow says the good news is that gives
us three months to pack stab to pass tax
reform that's not true okay I like Mark
Meadows but he's not right here okay Ben
Sasse is correct when Ben Sasse says the
problem is that by pushing if we really
wanted to set up for tax reform then we
would have gotten the government funded
now and we would have pushed off a debt
ceiling for longer than three months
because the problem is now Republicans
know in the back of their mind they're
gonna have to make some concessions to
Chuck Schumer in order for them to get
the debt ceiling in the budget and that
means they can't push for such a harsh
tax reform package because Schumer can
hold it hostage right Schumer can just
say listen you're not gonna get a single
Democrat vote on that and if you packs
the pass the tax reform know that
ceiling increase and no budget okay
Creed
serious problem here Allah puns it over
at hot air gets this exactly right he
says I think Trump honestly believes
Democrats are going to fund the border
wall in December as part of a grand
bargain to raise the debt ceiling in
avert of shot down he didn't want to
shut down with them over that right now
because the country is focused on storm
damage and won't stand for a needless
crisis of Uncle Sam's own making but he
does want to showdown with them
eventually sooner rather than later
that's the best explanation I can manage
for why he preferred a short-term
solution to the long-term one unless of
course he and his new friend Chuck
managed to blow up the debt ceiling
altogether before then that also
wouldn't be conducive to draining the
swamp but it would make fiscal standoffs
much harder for conservatives like sass
to engineer so in other words he's
saying maybe the best solute maybe the
best rationale for Trump doing this is
that he just didn't want to fight like
this moment because of Hurricane Harvey
but he had the upper hand in this fight
because if Democrats hold up funding for
hurricane Harvey then Republicans win we
know this because Democrats actually did
this over Hurricane sandy and
Republicans lost whichever party says
we're gonna hold up the debt ceiling
because we don't like what you're doing
with hurricane funding pays the price
they pay the political price that
actually happened back during hurricane
sandy if you recall it actually helped
Barack Obama when Republicans pushed for
fiscal restraint in the face of
Hurricane Harvey but Republicans are in
control right now it's just bad policy
all the way through and a lot of it is
coming from Trump's animus and ire for
the Republicans right now how do I know
that because Trump basically tweeted
that out this morning right this morning
Trump tweeted out Republicans sorry he
seriously tweeted this out Republican
sorry but I've been hearing about repeal
in her place for seven years didn't
happen even worse the Senate filibuster
rule never allowed the Republicans to
pass even great legislation eight Dems
control will rarely get 60 versus 51
votes it's a republic Republicans must
start the tax reform tax cut legislation
ASAP don't wait until the end of
September needed now more than ever
hurry okay well I understand that you're
saying now they have to hurry but the
problem is that they're gonna have to
hash this out legislation takes time it
doesn't magically appear in front of you
and this idea that Trump has this weird
idea of the presidency that was promoted
by some people who I like like Grover
Norquist that McConnell and Ryan we're
just gonna put legislation on his desk
and somehow this is gonna work that's
not how this is gonna work okay the
president has to take an active role in
shape
how this works because here's the truth
Trump isn't punishing Republicans it's
not that Republicans universally want
tax reform and now Trump is urging them
forward Republicans don't universally
want tax reform that's the whole point
they're a bunch of Republicans who are
happy to vote with Democrats on this
stuff and Trump by doing this is
actually granting them cover if you
don't get anything done now Trump is
basically gonna say well you know the
Republicans just couldn't get it done
and unless you're conservative in which
case you get bashed by your own base for
not supporting Trump let's say you're
Lindsey Graham and let's say you don't
support the tax reform package that's
put son and put on the table and Trump
says listen I gave you guys a chance and
you didn't do it now I'm working with
the Democrats you think that really
makes people like Susan Collins upset
you think she's sitting around going oh
no no I'm gonna have to vote with the
Democrats of course not the whole
critique of Republicans is that they
were too willing to work with Democrats
threatening Republicans by saying listen
if you guys won't work together I'm
gonna go work with the Democrats that
doesn't work at all
that doesn't work at all I mean that's
legitimately leg saying listen arsonist
who wants to burn down my house if you
try to burn down my house I'm telling
you right now if you try to burn down my
house and you don't succeed I'm gonna
set it on fire myself
hey what that does no no that's not how
any of this works the fact that this is
being driven my personal ire does not
make it good make Mulvaney whose Trump's
head of Office of Management and Budget
he basically came out and said that this
is all because Trump is mad at Ryan in
McConnell you know whether the president
is genuinely annoyed at Republicans in
the aggregate the leadership and that's
why he's reaching across the aisle
because he's fed up with him I just read
into what he did with Chuck Schumer
Nancy Pelosi on his debt thing as a sign
I'm sticking you guys I'll answer half
your question which is he annoyed with
the Republican leadership yeah I think
he probably is and believe me as a
Republican so am I as a citizen I am too
I was promised that they would have
repealed and replaced Obamacare by now
I'm a voter I have a member of Congress
I have a senator I've not only made
those promises to people for the last
seven years when I was running for
office people made them to me and I was
disappointed and somewhat annoyed that
we've not followed through on that
promise I don't think that's an
unnatural reaction at all and to the
extent that the president was annoyed by
that I think he's simply reflecting the
opinion of many
the people in country I agree we're all
annoyed by it I've been ripping on rhino
McConnell all year long I mean of course
we're all annoyed by it but the solution
to being annoyed by it is not to go over
to the other side I mean that was the
entire logic of Trump versus Hillary the
ins literally the entire logic of Trump
versus Hillary was we have to stop the
Democratic agenda it's not stopping the
Democratic agenda to vote with Pelosi
and Schumer okay that's just madness
what we're talking about right now and
by the way if you think that this is all
just a slap at Paul Ryan and he's really
upset in Mitch McConnell they're sitting
around crying into their beer because
Trump is working with Pelosi and Schumer
recognized something Republicans just
passed Trump's deal with Pelosi and
Schumer with majorities in both houses
okay here's Paul Ryan literally
yesterday - two days ago Paul Ryan said
that any attempt to connect hurricane
Harvey funding with the debt ceiling was
ridiculous irresponsible terrible Trump
flips and boom look at Paul Ryan now
we're getting hit with two hurricanes
we're still dealing with Harvey in Texas
Louisiana we were just now getting hit
with Irma and he wanted to make this a
bipartisan moment he wanted to make this
a bipartisan moment where we weren't
fighting each other up in Washington
about hurricane aid he just wanted to
get it done get it out of the way so
that aid is flowing to the states that
need it right now so that we can go and
then focus on things like tax reform so
it's perfectly reasonable rationale why
he's doing okay one thing this is the
worst idea ever Trump does it and all
the sudden he's fine with it does that
look like Ryan is very disappointed and
upset or does it look like he's kind of
willing to work with Democrats which was
the whole rip on him a year ago the
whole reason Trump was elected is
because it was conservatives right did
not even conservatives Republicans like
Ryan in McConnell these rhinos
constantly working with Democrats and
then Trump goes and works with Democrats
in revenge how's that revenge how's that
not giving them exactly what they want
and it's even worse than that okay Trump
on executive amnesty
okay so Trump let's just do a quick
flashback here okay let's remember what
happened over the past five years
here's 2012 here's Jeb Romick push in
2012 talking about how he supports the
so-called DREAM Act okay this was an act
to legalize all of the dreamers if
you're if you if the law says clearly
that you have a case-by-case right to
review cases and you blanket say 800,000
people comply that is way beyond the
purview
of executive power so I don't support
that I think to use the the power of the
presidency effectively you don't have to
use it for cynical reasons you don't
have to use it beyond what your power
with the Constitution allows but having
it having a solution to the fact that we
have all these young people many whom
are making great contributions don't
have a connection to their to their
parents former country yeah of course
I'm for it okay so that is him taking
Trump's exact position today right how
dare Barack Obama do the daca
but if the legislature wants to pass
some sort of solution that'd be great
right and remember in 2016 it wasn't
like Trump was shy about this in 2016 he
kept punching Jeb Bush through a wall
every five minutes over exactly this
position now I don't often agree with
Marco and I don't often agree with Ted
but I can in this case the weakest
person on this stage by far on illegal
immigration is Jeb Bush they come so
weak on illegal immigration it's
laughable and everybody knows it so you
know this this this is the standard
operating procedure to disparage me
that's fine and a little more money on
the commercials okay and that was what
Trump did the entire campaign it's why
people liked it because Jeb was weak
there's a pansy and there was Trump
beating him down like Donkey Kong I mean
just ripping him apart and now here's
Nancy Pelosi talking yesterday about
President Trump the guy who savaged Jeb
Bush here is Nancy Pelosi we made it
very clear in the course of it too
conversation that we would the priority
was to pass the DREAM Act that we wanted
to do it and obviously it has to be
bipartisan president said he would
actually supports that he would sign it
but we have to get it passed okay so
look how magical that is in the space of
five years Trump went from jeb bush's
the weakest / in spent of a year he went
from jeb bush's the weakest on
immigration to embracing jeb bush's
exact position
on the dreamers like word-for-word the
exact position hey is that a slap in the
face of the establishment guys like I
understand that you that we've now
redefined anti-establishment to just
mean whatever we want it to mean I
understand we've redefined Rhino to mean
whatever we wanted to mean but these
things used to have meanings right
anti-establishment used to mean you
opposed policies like Jeb Bush and you
didn't want to stand with the democrats
now anti-establishment means that you
want to stand against the Democrats
because Trump okay so if Trump declare
himself a Democrat tomorrow there would
be a contingent of Republicans who would
simply say well you know you're a real
Rhino if you don't go with Trump its
Trump's the ultimate Republican so if
Trump becomes a Democrat you should
become a Democrats you or you're a rhino
okay then that's weird how that all
happened in five seconds okay
well then well I want to get two things
I like in things I hate and listen I
hope that Trump pulls back from this I
hope that Trump stops with this
flirtation with the Democrats I don't
see that happening anytime in the near
future he's enjoying this too much he's
enjoying throwing everyone into chaos
he's enjoying ticking off supposedly
Ryan in McConnell he's enjoying the love
of the press please mr. president these
are not the policies that got you
elected these are not the people who got
you elected Pelosi and Schumer will
impeach you the first chance they get
for the love of Mike please for goodness
sake put a head back on your shoulders
and recognize you may hate Ryan you may
hate McConnell we're all disappointed in
them but this notion that you are going
to sit around making deals with the
Democrats because you must in order to
tick off members of your own party is
just a waste okay so we're gonna do
things I like things I hate and the mail
back but if you want to be part of the
mailbag today you need to subscribe
$9.99 a month got to a subscription so
daily wired.com and when you head over
there you not only get my show live you
also get Andrew Cleveland's show live
you get michael knowles new show live I
recommended Knowles to show you
yesterday it's quite good actually and
you get all of those show lives you get
to be part of their mailbag as well plus
you get our website without any ads at
all and when we upload the shows later
you can watch them without any ads which
is pretty awesome also if you get the
annual subscription you get this the
very finest in beverage containers the
leftist Cheers hot or cold tumbler
fabled spoken about in myth but now it
has come true all of the prophecies were
true all of them and now you can hold
this in your very hands the leftist
here's hot or cold tumbler you got that
with your $99 a year annual subscription
you should do that anyway because
hey who wants to see that $9.99 a month
come off your bill every month you may
as well just get the annual and then you
get a really nice mug that you can store
anything you want and please make it
just beverages okay so also if you just
want to listen later make sure you head
over to a u2 SoundCloud or iTunes also
please head over to YouTube we have a
daily wired channel over at YouTube
please become a subscriber because when
you do that then you make sure that you
get all of our videos automatically so
do that as well all of that helps we are
the largest and fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay time for some things I like and
then some things I hate and the mailbag
so the things I like before I get to a
I first want to point out that Berkeley
has now released the tickets it's too
late they sold out in 45 minutes in
legitimately 45 minutes they sold out a
thousand tickets okay they had cut out
the they cut off the other thousand
tickets because that's what Berkeley
does because they're afraid auntie fool
is gonna come in and grab chairs and
fling them over the railings and murder
people basically but Berkeley should
obviously release the other thousand
tickets okay we have at least 3,000
people who want the tickets at least
3,000 probably more at this point
probably four or five thousand people
who want the tickets in Berkeley has
restricted the venue because they can't
protect it but they're taking security
measures that are absolutely amazing I
mean the security measures that they're
taking because man Tifa are
extraordinary they're actually locking
down six separate buildings apparently
six buildings outside the one I'm
speaking in okay in a campus-wide email
on Thursday this according to James
Barrett over at Daily wire Berkeley's
executive vice chancellor and provost
Paul alavés alavés Sato's detailed the
steps the university is taking in order
to keep things on campus from devolving
into chaos because I am arriving
apparently well there they are locking
down a bunch of buildings they're
shutting down multiple buildings and
parking lots to create a closed
perimeter around Zellerbach Pot where
I'm speaking I mean this is this is
scary stuff folks they're creating a
secure perimeter by shutting down
buildings providing alternative options
for faculty staff and students so they
can try to engage in the regular
academic activities without fear of
violence erupting so there's still
classes going on around that time
they're trying to find them alternative
classrooms with police guards basically
today Nancy if it doesn't attack normal
students imposing special restrictions
on tickets and ID's you have to show up
they're only selling them one at a time
you can't buy a block of tickets so
everybody has to show up and personally
show an ID in order to pick up the
ticket which is an insane process and
they're offering support and counseling
services for faculty staff and students
because I might hurt your feelings so
obviously the real threat here is not
the people who might throw chairs into
the audience it's me because why I might
hurt your feelings oh you need some
counseling and Tifa by the way has
released its own poster they don't call
themselves nt4 they call themselves
refused fascism but I am a fascist
apparently you know despite the fact
that I have spent my entire career being
anti-fascist
and ripping me alright and suggesting me
outright are garbage people with garbage
beliefs and fighting fascism my entire
career no i am the real fascist it's
pretty amazing
also worth noting the berkeley student
senate wanted to pass a resolution
condemning berkeley subsidizing my
events next week but it failed by a vote
of fifteen to five that vote failed by a
vote of fifteen to five because there
are a bunch of student senators who were
upset that the resolution was too broad
he wanted to create two bills one
condemning the subsidization of my
events and the other condemning hate
speech in general then that's because
they didn't want to lump me in with
other people who were engaged in hate
speech so good on some of the berkeley
students who recognize that not all
speech is is exactly the same although
the hate speech notion itself is sort of
ridiculous because it's absolutely
changeable under under any circumstances
okay so the event at berkeley is gonna
go forward if you're upset that you
can't get a ticket feel free to call in
and register your disapproval politely
politely always be polite we're the good
guys here okay so be polite and i will
see you at berkeley and i will give you
more updates next week this is dangerous
stuff locking down full buildings
craziness Wow but I'm the fascist by the
way my speech is called fighting campus
thuggery and the aunty Fay posture says
I'm the real thug okay they're not
locking down the top level because of me
I'm not the one tossing chairs you
morons okay time for another thing that
I like so there's a series that I've
just started watching I cannot vouch for
the entire series I came out for like
the first three episodes which I've seen
so far hopefully it holds up and has
like ninety four percent on Rotten
Tomatoes there is some random nudity for
no reason because it was made in Europe
and that's just what Europeans do but
here is it's it's available on Amazon
the show is called fortitude
[Music]
we live on the one place on earth we're
guaranteed a quiet life
we're lovers of the wilderness lovers of
the Northern Lights or just lovers
can witness the wildest things they'll
ever see
from the safest place on earth so
naturally it doesn't end up being the
safest place you might have gotten that
from like the fact that it's a show if
it was just the safest place on earth
that'd be the most boring show ever but
it's it's I'm interested to see where
it's going it's got sort of a slightly
supernatural element to it
I wouldn't say too much it's it feels
sort of like a mixture between the stand
and and wherever they filmed Batman
Begins when Batman is training that's
basically that's basically the mashup
but I can vouch in the first four
episodes and they're good okay time for
a a thing that I hate and then we'll do
the meal you know what let's get the
thing I hate let's spend more time on
mailbag today because I hate so many
things like what's the point okay so
let's just go straight to the mailbag
and we'll take your questions live as
well Stephen says what made you choose
the violin so when you're five years old
which is when I started playing you
don't actually have the capacity to
choose anything so as my parents who
chose the violin for me the reason was
because just sort of by random
coincidence I had a blanky and the
blanky had letters on it they had
pictures for each letter and in one
corner was a V for violin and I and I
was constantly kind of sucking on the
corner of the blanky when I was like
three that had the V for violin and and
so they said okay violin it is and I
ended up being good at it I think I'm
gonna get my kids started on instruments
soon the oldest one is three and a half
and I think that next year when she's
four I'm gonna get her started on the
instrument she says she wants to play
cello interestingly she's very
sophisticated three and a half year old
like really she went when we are in the
car I say what you want to listen to and
she'll say the Firebird like by
Stravinsky right she really says this
like the music that she like she also
likes Beethoven's 6th she likes a lot of
the music from Fantasia and also she
likes in the hall of the Mountain King
by Greg these are some of her favorites
okay Jonathan says John Frey he says
dear Ben I'm wondering what your opinion
is on the drinking age some people argue
if you're able to go to war and vote you
should also be able to drink do you
agree with this yes I agree with this if
you're old enough to make a decision
about voting you're old enough to make a
decision about drinking and also don't
make stupid decisions generally but yeah
if we're gonna set the voting age at 18
or you can serve in the military at 18
or get a job at 18 yes you should be
able to drink if you see fit
Devon says thank you for all the great
content I'm a store manager for a large
company my company loves to hire 18
22 year olds for high-pressure sales
jobs I'm having trouble getting them
motivated to do the work necessary to be
successful any suggestions on managing
immature young people well I mean I
think the only advice that I would give
is the hard advice which is do the job
or you're fired
basically like learning the consequences
of life right here this is a hard job
it's an exciting job you can make a lot
of money but you need to do the worker
on the can you right kids need
consequences this is this is a funny
thing about parenting now is that as a
parent I know because you have you love
your children so much and this is true
of young people you love your children
so much that you think that the worst
thing you can do to them is set
boundaries and rules kids like
boundaries and rules they want to know
that the world is safe and they want to
know that there's a set of rules that if
they follow everything is going to be
okay
this is also true for people who are 18
to 22 is true for all people that they
want to know what the rules are they
want to know the rules of the game you
know I've worked with young people at
this company for a long time I'm still a
relatively young person and I was a
syndicated columnist in now seventeen so
I was very successful when I was very
young but when I work with young people
at the company basically they know you
have a responsibility your
responsibility is to produce acts I'm
not gonna micromanage you right if I
hired the right person I don't have to
micromanage you actually people at the
company know this I prefer not to
interact in terms of managing your job
your job is your job I'm gonna tell you
what I need you to do and you're going
to do it and if you don't do it you're
gonna get fired and it's that simple and
it has nothing to do with like or
dislike you have a job to do and the
better you do your job and more I like
the job you do I think that you set that
standard very early on I think that
young people understand that and they
respect that I think it's the same thing
with teachers teachers who want to be
friends with their students it's a total
fail but teachers to say listen you work
hard you'll get an A you don't work hard
you'll get an F I think students
appreciate that Nick says there's a bit
of a personal question but I'll just get
right to it last year my dad cheated on
my mom my mom caught him and said he was
going to end it never did my parents are
currently getting divorced and he's
become more open about dating this woman
he had the affair with nothing has
changed with the way he treated me he
still treats me great and we have a good
relationship however I'm finding it hard
to still respect the man I love him but
this has definitely put a strain on our
relationship what should I do
should I just accept him with his faults
or treat him with respect but never
truly forgive him Thanks well I'm not
sure that he asked you for forgiveness
and obviously forgiveness would also
require repentance like in Judea
there's a difference between forgiveness
and repentance if you are if you are
asking for my forgiveness you have to
stop doing what you are doing okay you
can't just if you're punching me in the
face in the middle you say I'm really
sorry
and then you punch me in the face again
I can't forgive you okay the whole point
of you repenting is that you stop doing
what you're doing now in this particular
case it sounds like your parents are
currently getting divorced and it's not
getting put back together I think that
your best move is probably just to
accept that your dad is a deeply flawed
human being um I don't think it's
inappropriate for you to be angry at
your father or feel angry with him your
feelings are totally justified I think
but if you want to live a happier life I
think that you're going to have to just
accept their dad is a flawed person that
the relationship between your parents is
really between them I think your mom
will probably understand this as well
and I listen if God forbid that happened
with my parents I would certainly have
trust issues with my father for the rest
of his life for certain so I can't blame
you for having those trust issues but I
think that reliving this over and over
is not going to be a productive
experience if you want to have a
relationship with him if you don't want
to have a relationship with him then
that's a choice you can make as well and
that also I don't think it's a
completely unreasonable choice Alexander
says hey Ben
why is tribalism acceptable in religious
contexts like Judaism but unacceptable
in political context so tribalism in
Judaism is supposed to be about the
ideas of Judaism so religious tribalism
is about the ideas okay ethnic tribalism
is about nothing having to do with ideas
it's about outward manifestations right
it's about race or sex or stuff that's
not supposed to make a difference right
there is a real philosophical and
political difference between Judaism and
other religions just like there is
between Christianity and other religions
or Islam and other religions these are
distinctions that make a difference in
how you lead your life so there can be
ideological tribalism that's not really
tribalism that's ideology now what's
weird about Judaism is that Judaism does
have an ethnic component but you can
convert into Judaism right it's not
purely ethnic if you decide that you
want to become a Jew you can convert and
become a Jew if Judaism or purely ethnic
then the suggestion would be that you
can't become a Jew no matter what and
that if you and that and and and
therefore we only accept people of a
particular bloodline that's not correct
if you want to convert we will accept
your conversion we also don't believe by
the way that if you're not Jewish that
you can't get into have
interview good person or anything it's
one of the weird things about Judaism as
opposed to other religions we're not
exclusive in our access to to God or
heaven so that's so that's worth noting
as well you know the the people ask me
all the time from a Jewish perspective
and I'm not gonna give the halacha the
Jewish perspective I mean to my own
perspective no there's a lot about
ethnic Judaism in Judaism this idea that
you have allegiance to people who are
ethnically Jewish okay I don't really
feel strong allegiance to people who are
quote unquote ethnically Jewish just
because they were born and have a last
name that ends in gold or sting like
that doesn't seem to like Noam Chomsky
if if I had a choice between saving
Malthus and no I'm Chomsky that is the
easiest choice in the world neither no
the easiest choice in the world would be
Malthus obviously no I'm Chomsky's a
garbage human being I I'm not a big fan
of the idea that ethnicity defines your
goodness or badness the ethnic Judaism
just has to do with who is considered a
Jew initially in Judaism and and who can
be part of the Jewish people but again
you can convert in when Shani says your
been my question is in the eyes of God
how is killing during war different than
murder and what about collateral damage
when so-called innocents lose their
lives
fYI totally obsessed with you not in a
Glenn Close fatal attraction type of way
but really close lol well that would
explain the dead rabbit but as far as
how is killing during war different than
murder killing xournal war is different
than murder because presumably the
people on the other side are trying to
kill you so it's more self-defense this
is why there's all sorts reams of
religious literature and moral
literature about what justifies war is
pre-emptive war justified if you're
protecting your own life the idea of a
purely aggressive war is sort of foreign
to moral concepts the idea of I'm just
gonna go to war because I want your
resources most moral people don't
believe that's a thing but if you are
fighting an army that's determined to
conquer you invade your rights kill you
change your way of life then that
changes the math somewhat as far as
collateral damage the this is a serious
problem that moral people also have to
consider which is if I have to just if I
have to fight that army how guilty are
the innocents who are associated with
that army so this actually has a lot of
moral complexity to it so going back to
the time of Napoleon before Napoleon
actually these were very easy questions
because there were civilians and then
there were people who are military and
the military people were basically Lords
who would rise
their armor and hit each other and then
they'd have armies that they hired to
hit each other and they'd go out to the
middle of a field and fight each other
that made things a lot clearer Napoleon
was the first world leader who actually
integrated civilian with military so he
said all Frenchmen are now soldiers
right if you are a Frenchman and you
have a farm
your farm is now a stock place for goods
for the military there is no distinction
anymore between civilian and military
this move has really changed the nature
of warfare in large scale so his
democracy because the argument is made
that if you voted for Hitler then you're
part of Hitler's army sort of you know
it's an argument but the chief rule for
morale folks is you try to avoid
collateral damage as much as possible
that's why the United that's why the
Geneva Conventions exist it's to try to
avoid collateral damage it's also why
it's so incredibly stupid when people
say the terrorists ought to have rights
under the Geneva Convention the whole
point of a terrorist is that a terrorist
hides in a civilian area not wearing a
military uniform the whole point of the
Geneva Conventions is to try to make
your enemy wear a military uniform so
you know who it's okay to kill if they
hide is a civilian and they hide in a
civilian area you don't know who it's
okay to kill and then you end up killing
a bunch of innocent people that's the
whole point is why you shouldn't give
the same rights to people who dress up
like civilians and then act as
terrorists as people who are in military
uniform right this is why there's an in
uniform out of uniform distinction in
international law Joseph says hey Ben
what's his cruel and unusual punishment
mean within the context of the Bill of
Rights everyone I see mentioned it uses
a subjective interpretation but I feel
as if that's not what the founders
intended Thanks well so I believe in the
in the Clarence Thomas Justice Scalia
originalism view of cruel and unusual
punishment so you'd have to go back and
look at what was considered cruel and
unusual at the time there's this very
very weird notion on the left that cruel
and unusual punishment includes the
death penalty clearly it does not
include the death penalty okay there's
an actual penalty prescribed in the
Constitution for treason and it is death
so the same people who wrote the cruel
and unusual punishment ban would not
have also prescribed death if they
thought it was a cruel and unusual
punishment what they're probably talking
about is forms of torture that were used
pretty commonly at the time in in
monarchies and you can look up the forms
of torture that were used largely the
time and considered cruel and unusual
but you have to go back to the time and
measure it by those standards Seth says
taught to me in college to the 51% of
refugees their children can you explain
the difference between refugees asylum
seekers and other migrants to show that
the threat of a heavily young male
migrant population is real so there are
asylum seekers these are people who
presumably legally speaking anyway these
are people who presumably are coming
from a place where they are in danger
and we try to grant them asylum to
protect them from the country where they
are that they are fleeing there are
refugees where people of any sort or
just fleeing from a dangerous country
right they're not specific targets
asylum seekers usually are specific
targets refugees are just people fleeing
from a bad situation and migrants are
people who are coming for work so a lot
of the people who are coming to Europe
right now a huge percentage of them are
male and they are young and they are
setting up so the argument is that a lot
of them are coming over and setting up
sort of a financially secure situation
before bringing the rest of their family
in but this also does create some
questions about whether these are actual
refugees or they're more economic
migrants are these people who are using
the refugee situation as a lever in
order to get into Europe or are these
people who are actually fleeing if they
were just playing you know just getting
out wholesale you would expect more
women and children Saez says what are
your thoughts on price increases during
natural disasters so you think it's
acceptable under supply and demand
principles or do you think it's wrong
and should not be done so I think that
supply and demand is hears so let's for
this way let's say that you're a grocery
store you have a hundred bottles of
water in your grocery store and there
are four hundred people who want the
bottles of water how exactly are you
gonna decide which hundred people get
the bottles of water is it wrong for you
to say the people who can afford the
bottles of water ought to get the
bottles of water should you go to first
come first serve and not raise your
prices
well maybe you might think that out of
charity you're going to do that but
here's the problem if you are a company
that is shipping the water bottles down
to that area and now it's more dangerous
to ship the bottles down to that area
because there's a hurricane how are you
gonna incentivize that company to get
those bottles down into that area now
during a natural disaster there's a
feeling that everyone should unite and
basically put profit aside but it is
just naturally more expensive you have
to pay somebody more to drive through a
hurricane to get the water bottles to
the store that means the price increases
so whenever there's a natural disaster
it creates more scarcity more scarcity
means you have to go through more in
order to get the product there that
means the prices are going to increase I
do not think it is immoral for prices to
increase during a natural
Jasser as you think it is charitable to
try and prevent the prices from
increasing okay so it's both right so
it's I don't think immoral for prices to
increase I don't think are screwing
anyone I don't think that's the goal I
think that's a recognition of economic
reality and I think it also incentivizes
people who are not charitable to bring
more goods into a bad area
I think it's charitable if you can do it
to to lower prices voluntarily Adam says
would you rather have dinner with Barack
Obama or Donald Trump which one could
you see yourself having a better
conversation with so that sounds like a
horror of a dinner choice I mean that's
like f marry kill with like Michael
Moore Rosie O'Donnell and no I'm chomps
game yeah that's just awful so you know
would I rather have dinner with Barack
Obama let's put this way I think I could
have a conversation about literature and
movies with Barack Obama I'm not sure I
could with Donald Trump yeah I think
that Donald Trump and I like it seems to
me that all of his conversations just be
awful anyway Brock would just sit there
talking about how great he is and then
Trump would sit there talking about how
great he is and I'd be so bored but I
get the feeling that conversation with
Obama would just be on an intellectual
level a little more stimulating than
conversation with Trump but that's not
because I agree with Obama I think
they're both I think Obama is a horror
show I think I agree with Trump on more
things but I actually enjoy sometimes
talking with people with whom I disagree
anyone okay Evan says what TV shows do
you let your kids watch so I don't
actually let my kids watch TV shows I
let my kids watch old movies so I don't
let the young one is still under the age
of two he doesn't watch TV the one who
is three and a half she is old Disney
movies so she's seen a lot of the old
Disney movies it's like Bambi she
watches Fantasia a lot right now she's
in that stage and and she watches a lot
of old musicals so she knows singing in
the rain she knows summer stock she
knows her favorite is Seven Brides for
Seven Brothers she loves Seven Brides
for Seven Brothers this is how my
parents brought me up we used to go to a
store out here called Eddie Brant
Saturday matinee which is the sort of
the great video store in Los Angeles and
these two rents old episodes of Dick Van
Dyke in the Waltons and old movies and
so that's why I've seen so many old
movies she's being brought up along the
same lines Austin says in the instance
the children end up in a situation where
they have no caregivers family is killed
by natural disaster for example who do
you believe should be responsible for
taking care of those children private
charity church communities nonprofit or
government using taxpayers so I
you're that that is the order of that
that is the order of preference so
friends and family after that private
charities through religious communities
and after that the government the
government should always be the lender
of last resort essentially because the
fact is the government care is all is
real I mean foster care and government
care is is very very difficult and the
adoption process is far too complex
thanks to government ok that brings us
to the end of today's mailbag if you did
not get into today's mailbag then you
should subscribe because next week is
gonna be a fun mailbag if I survived
Berkeley next Thursday there will be a
mailbag next Friday and we can talk all
about it next week will be a big
important week not just because of
Berkeley but also because we will see
where President Trump goes next which
will be fascinating plus we'll keep you
updated on all the hurricanes and the
disasters because clearly something
weird is going on I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]